في الجو في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
المسيرات في قلب المعركه واستخدامها يتم
بوتيره متسارعه رغم محدوديه ما تحققه على
الارض الا ان الاثر المعنوي لها يكمن في
قدرته على الاختراق والوصول اربع مناطق
منفصله في روسيا تعرضت لهجمه بطائره بدون
طيار شملت كورس كوارستوف وبالقرود على
الحدود مع اوكرانيا لكن العاصمه موسكو لم
تسلم ايضا في كورسكا غربيه روسيا تحطمت
مسيره على سقف محطه قطار بينما لم تقع
اصابه في هجوم روستوف اما في مقاطعه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان المضادات الجويه تمكنت
من احباط هجوم بثلاث مسيرات دون اضرار كما
تحدثت عن صد الطائره مسيره اوكرانيا في
منطقه موسكو وتحطمها في منطقه غير ماهوله
ما اوقف لفتره وجيزه رحلت الى مطاري فوني
بالعاصمه اكثر من 140 هجوما جويا بدون
طيار هذا العام وفق تقارير وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه حدثت في روسيا والاراضي التي
تسيطر عليها في اوكرانيا تركزت هذه
الهجمات في بريانسكو بالقرود بالقرب من
الحدود الغربيه لروسيا وكذلك في شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا والعاصمه موسكو
كان اخطرتها اتهام روسيا اوكرانيا بمحاوله
اغتيال الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين في هجوم
بمسيره استهدف الكريم
لفت ايضا استخدام المسيرات في استهداف
المنشاه النفطيه والمطارات والبنيه
التحتيه للطاقه اما من حيث طبيعتها فبرز
استخدام كياب الطائرات بدون طيار من نوع
يوجي 22 ويبلغ مداها نحو 800 كيلومتر فضلا
عن طائرات بمقدار التركيه باثنين تلك
معركه الجوي بالمسيرات تساعدها كياف لكن
عينها ايضا على الطائرات المقاتله
قائد القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه اكد ان
العمل بدا لتجهيز مدارج الطائرات كي تكون
صالحه للاستخدام ومناسبه لاستقبال مقاتلات
يتعلق الامر بمقاتلات اف 16 الامريكيه
كاولويه قصوى لكن السعي قائم ايضا للحصول
على الطائره السويديه
ثم المقاتل البريطاني تايفون تليها مقاتله
رافال الفرنسيه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني قال
ان الطيارين الاوكرانيين بداوا التدريب
على تشغيل الطائرات وقد يستغرق ذلك سته
اشهر على الاقل ولهذا بدات متحفزا هنا في
قاعده للقوات الجويه الهولنديه مع رئيس
الوزراء الهولندي
روتاكد التزامه هولندا والدنمارك بتزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتله اف 16 بمجرد استيفاء
كياب للشروط وفي الدنمارك التي وصلها وفي
قاعده الجويه وفي صوره محمله برسائل جلس
الرئيس الاوكراني على مقاعد الطائره
مقاتله من طراز اف 16 الى جانب رئيسه
الوزراء الدنماركيه
التي اعلنت التبرع لاوكرانيا بتسعه عشره
مقاتله من هذا النوع
ريهانو كييف وفق تصريحات مسؤوليها على احد
ابرز مفاتيح التفوق وقلب معادله المعارك
المقاتلات لكن بمقابلها حسابات وعوامل
تعوض عليها روسيا للتفوق على ارض المعركه